but first he writes the nationally
syndicated column savage love hostess
Savage love podcast Dan Savage
[Applause]
great to see you how are you sir
I've got hurried right to see you I
wanted to talk to you about so many
things but let's start with the tweet I
mean I didn't when I saw this yesterday
I just thought oh a disgusting obnoxious
tweet from Donald Trump it's erectus
bullying [ __ ] reveals himself to be
sexist bullying ass right everybody went
ape [ __ ] and I just don't understand it
why why is this the camel the camel the
straw that broke the camel's back I mean
this is the guy who talked about
grabbing [ __ ] uninvited this is the
guy who's before he was president is
that what it is megan kelly thing
happened before he was president when a
lot of us were like this is not going to
happen right a lot of us believe then
that he wasn't going to be president it
has a different quality when the
president does the exact same thing that
he did when he was the candidate people
keep hoping he's going to pivot to
something more presidential how many
times have we heard people on TV say ah
tonight he became president well tonight
he became the ow so he's always been or
yesterday again
and I also think you know all women who
are premenopausal men straight and so
talking like what he said about megyn
kelly blood coming out of her wherever
wasn't as scalding as sort of the
sensitive subject of like outing someone
about plastic surgery because people
sometimes have hang-ups about being out
about that so it seemed even crueler
than just referencing the bleeding that
people generally do women people
generally do this is a different kind of
bloody and a different kind of have onto
another subject area explored and you've
answered my question
so I do write about some work last week
I was talking about how the Democratic
Party can kind of get back in the game
because they've lost all four special
elections okay and Bernie Sanders said
recently the current model and strategy
of the Democratic Party is an absolute
failure which probably is why he doesn't
join it do you think that's true and
what do you think about what the
Democrats should do well the Republicans
lost all four special elections in 2009
and then they won in 2010 so in 2009
there were special elections after Obama
appointed Democrats from safe seats his
administration and the Republicans
didn't win any of those seats didn't
pick any of them up and then the
Democrats got their asses handed to them
in the first midterm so the fact that
the Democrats haven't won any yet
doesn't mean that we still can't hand
them their asses in the midterm and
[Applause]
to your point low whatever a good
attitude to have no no we got to keep
fighting
yeah and we're going to win but we can't
we can't like point to these losses as
evidence we can never win because that's
just becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
and then we will never win but what
Bernie said and you've said this a lot
the Democrats have to start fighting
like Republicans which may include
cheating like Republicans Republicans
women Republicans Chief Democrats she
yes Democrats Hillary Clinton won the
popular vote started Al Gore so did Al
Gore but that was I think a theft but
Democrats Democratic candidates took a
million more votes and House races but
for gerrymandering Democrats would have
a majority in the house the system is
rigged like Bernie Sanders said but it's
rigged against partly it's rigged
because Democrats didn't vote enough and
so the state legislatures are controlled
by Republicans that's who draws up the
districts right and Democrats need to
get that are driving out their voters
and inspiring about is to turn up by
actually having some position even for
the little ones yes absolutely not just
the top of the ticket and also stand you
know stand together you know support
each other I was talking about how John
all stuff related in support Nancy
Pelosi when that you know they were
going after her and he said why I've
been given it any thought I mean that's
not what Republicans would do no
Republicans are a gay all right right
like a prison gang like a prison prison
guy and that's where our politics are
yeah right Republicans have brass
knuckles on and Democrats don't and
Democrats need to pick up the brass
knuckles and play the game that's
actually being played so many Democrats
think that very in Washington to set a
good example for the GOP and we need to
start fighting like the GOP fights and
even fighting as dirty as the GOP fights
okay glad you feel that way
there's also the part of it that so many
people in this country in so many states
would never consider voting for through
a Democrat it's not just that they're
not the preferred party they're
unthinkable Vladimir Putin to them is
preferable to a Democrat why do you
think that is and how can we reverse
that how can we make people in North
Dakota go
okay I'll at least look at the Democrat
I don't know but I will say that I think
that might be the wrong question because
when you when you look at the map
there's no such thing as a blue state
there are red states with big blue
cities in them oh I know good I go to
them all right that flipped the state
you know Washington State where I live
is a red state but for Seattle and when
Democrats have to do is they have to
unapologetically be the party of urban
America the way the Republicans are
unapologetically the party of
depopulated America the party of rural
America the party of the exurbs and
suburbs Democrats have to be the urban
party Republicans for 30 40 years
San Francisco values and demonizing
urbanites people of color and the elites
that live in the cities and Democrats
have to turn out more of those voters in
the cities and more of those voters will
turnout in the cities if Democrats
embrace that but Democrats say we are
the party of the places where people are
it sounds like you're saying we should
write off the very people who won the
last election for Donald Trump if more
people turned out in the cities to vote
in all the cities to vote Donald Trump
would not have won the election
Democrats have to do a better job of
turning those people out and stop
chasing voters they're never going to
get sending John Kerry out with a gun to
shoot something right before the
election didn't win him any votes in
knuckle-dragger merica okay let me ask
you about this one
[Music]
according to the right-wing spin spin
machine the greatest threat to America
now that liberals are violent can you
show a little bit of the said this
played in the Georgia election not by
this I must say this was not bought by
the Republican Party down there but a
sympathetic arm of the Republican Party
and this shows where they're at now the
unhinge left is endorsing and applauding
shooting Republicans when will it stop
it won't if John Asaf wins on Tuesday
because the same unhinged leftist
cheering last week shooting are all
backing John Asaf and if he wins they
win stop them stop him now stop John
Asaf stop Nancy Pelosi vote karen handel
for congress well they stopped us
awesome loss i guess it's over right
well let's see that's what they do but
this idea this is not just this one it I
could read I have so many quotes here
I'm not going to read them all Sean
Hannity Jean Pierre all the people on
the right the NRA retina NRA ed who are
saying things like liberal hatred
towards President Trump and Republicans
have reached a fever pitch and now what
is becoming violent wait I thought we
were snowflakes we were smoking now
though and now any minute Kathy Griffin
might be coming in with the head severed
off a bit we are trying to put this over
that we are the violent one right we
used to be the latte-sipping Volvo
driving New York Times reading sushi
eating liberal elite [ __ ] in the
cities and now we're this danger and but
the reason they're doing this the reason
they're cranking this up gun sales
plummeted after Trump won the election
because the scary black president wasn't
coming for your guns anymore not that he
ever did and the shrill lady wasn't
going to come for your guns and gun
sales went off the cliff after Trump
left the election this crazy NRA ad all
of this rhetoric what they're saying is
hey don't stop buying guns go buy some
[ __ ] guns because Kathy Griffin is
going to come and kill you now instead
of
it's a transparent but it's a certain
effort to scare people who are easily
scared and to drive them into gun shops
department also shows that when they
want to get on a page they they are do
that's what the Democrats don't do they
meet in their underground lair to do
their volcano and they say okay tomorrow
we are all going to say that the left is
unhinged and violent even though it's
crazy and so many of us goes wait the
left is not violent yeah but we're going
to say that we're all going to say that
and then it's become true to at least
half the country Democrats need to do
that don't you think I need to have an
underground lair where they come up with
it and they all say it they never do
that they don't all say the same just
letting big gay bar where we all meet
once a year to make your plan I what if
I want to feel comfort like Macross are
terrible at messaging the example I
always think of is a couple years ago a
Republican strategist said stop calling
them entitlements and tie-dye are bad
people are entitled call them earned
benefits you paid into Social Security
you paid into Medicare
you earned it and Democrats couldn't
make that quick and that global warming
global warming is kind of nice that is a
call with climatic you know the
Democrats actually you know the gay bar
thing they should look to it the gays
did we talked about gay marriage and
people are like ooh yuck because gay
says sex gay says sex oh we all switched
we started saying marriage equality
right even people are uncomfortable with
the gays doing the gay but thing could
get behind could get behind equality and
it really helped us achieve marriage
equality and Democrats should look to
the success of one of the biggest social
movements in this country in the last
thirty years and what we achieved in
part by effective messaging with
everybody on the same page for [ __ ]
sake stop calling them entitlements make
that switch if nothing else Republicans
you know death panels death taxes they
always partial birth abortion they
repeat this stuff until we on the Left
can't even think of these issues without
going to their rhetoric Democrats have
the power to do the same thing if they
will all unite and have one message like
you
quality
thank you